mais cette nomination de
castaner samedi élections désignation ça
peut là aussi quand même ça commence
déjà suscité pas mal de remous
il risque d'être mal élu parce que trop
bien et lui justement moi la question
précédente et c'est aussi une façon de
vous répondre là je dirais oui et non
car oui ça peut faire pschitt dans le
sens où il ya ya ya eu un tel appel
d'air que ça aussi créer un espoir ni
presse qu'une illusion du c'est l'idée
du bottom pas on va la retrouver
d'ailleurs sur les banlieues 1 peut se
dire que tout ce qui comme des réseaux
sociaux si vous le soudain coûte qui
arrive de la base bar à vin immergées on
va tous avoir droit au chapitre etc
il ya un moment donné on s'aperçoit que
ce n'est pas le cas donc forcément le
souffle et redescend un peu en même
temps l'objectif précisément de la
convention à lyon et aussi de
s'organiser et il faut bien que
mouvement parti peu importe comment
l'appel
ils s'organisent pour structurer sa
présence politique structuré sa présence
dans les instances locales parce que
province pour l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas donc il faut bien aussi qu'ils
s'organisent un minimum donc de ce point
de vue là je dirais non ça ne va pas
faire pschitt parce que c'est
précisément l'objet c'est de se
structurer en l'occurrence c'est
christophe castaner qui s'est vu confier
par emmanuel macron parce que c'est bien
ça qu'il s'est passé les rênes de
l'appareil mais il ya bien une volonté
de se structurer pour précisément aussi
ne pas faire pschitt